As we wrap up this course, I'd like to point out that animation production with a game engine is a challenging but rewarding process.
Sequencer's feature set is designed to address many production requirements, however, there are many things that you can do to make your experience in engine a more productive one.
The first thing you can do is to concentrate on project and level organization.
Unreal, as a game engine, is designed to achieve real-time results within the limits of existing GPU hardware.
Unlike traditional production that usually has much more computational resources, you should go into your project prepared with a plan to optimize your environments and animation performances for greater efficiency based on your GPU's capabilities.
By learning how to use a game engine, you're effectively becoming a better production artist.
Most linear content projects rely on large environments and multiple scene setups for shot-based workflows.
One of the ways that Epic addresses this issue is by using levels and sub-levels, whereas game productions will likely use world partitions for open-world game play.
The level editor is a critical tool for organizing your environment by creating specific sub-levels.
The primary level or map that pairs to your master level sequence will contain what is known as the persistent level.
By default, everything resides here, including anything new added to the level, but once artists start creating additional sub-levels, they're more free to assign different purposes to them.
By double-clicking on any one of these additional sub-levels, newly added actors can be placed within them.
Depending upon your particular project, levels and sub-levels can be used for environmental organization, sequence lighting setups, effects, special camera moves, or whatever you need.
Then within Sequencer, these levels can be turned on or off by using visibility tracks.
The result allows the artist to selectively visualize portions of the environment on a scene-by-scene basis.
Another technique to help keep yourself and your project running smoothly is to create a logically organized nested folder structure within your content browser and project outliner as much as possible.
While some studios do have their own organizational techniques, many do not.
Lack of a common folder structure can make it difficult to hand off projects to other members on your team.
A considerable amount of time is wasted by artists trying to dissect other people's work.
Make it easier on them and adopt this technique, especially if you're working within a group.
Project organization remains one of the most important aspects of any production.
In order to improve your chances of success, Epic has collected a number of relevant production tips and resources that can help you along the way.
We'll take a look at those in our next session.